Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Tja, Infektionszahlen steigen, alle wollen, dass sie sinken, aber wer ist dagegen.
Wie immer die Ansammlung frustrierter Deutscher.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundzweiundsiebzig vom elften zwölften zwanzig.
Das Jahr kommt langsam dem Ende entgegen. Dann geht's los, die goldenen Zwanziger, du warst schon.
Aber was haben wir gelernt? Immerhin ein paar Mitglieder der Regierung haben äh durchaus hm ihren Humor behalten einerseits so und äh können auch richtig Emo, wie wir festgestellt haben.
Angela Merkel hat Emotionen. Meldung.
Breaking News. Ja, ist ja mal was.
Da haben wir kaum sterben fünfhundert Leute am Tag kommt die Frau durch, ne? Aber sich doch direkt die ganze Zeit gesagt, dass wir nicht von einer Frau regiert werden können, die sind viel zu emotional. Ja.
Ciao. Genau und äh das von dir zitierte ähm Stückchenbezeichnung ist äh kommt von unserem Außenminister, ja, wer hätte es gedacht, das da hat er sich richtig.
Hätte es gedacht, ja, Angela Merkel hat Emotionen und Heiko Maas hat irgendwas, was man im Bereich kreativen Humor ansiedeln könnte.
Fragt man sich echt, warum das? Also vielleicht ist das auch einfach die ganze Zeit an mir vorbeigegangen, ist schon längst etabliert, aber das ist einfach so die, also das einfach die Bezeichnung, ne, was also.
Steht jedem,
in jedem dieser Vertreterinnen einfach so was von im Gesicht, ne. Frustrierte Deutsche. Ja, also das ist einfach jetzt der der Begriff, der ist jetzt so.
Am Ende immer alle überrascht. Ich finde das gut, also sollen die sich mal äh da locker machen, also das glaube ich auch, sagen wir mal, generell äh ein ordentlicher ähm,
Umgang und ich finde auch so frustrierte Deutsche, das trifft's einfach auch echt ins Mark. Also das ist irgendwie da da da hüpft doch die Weide schon wieder von einem,
Bein aufs andere, weißt du?
Also ich habe das ja schon mal hier gesagt, ich ich finde das so.
Also dich anzuschauen, ja, wie die drauf sind. Ich meine, guck mal, du musst dir vor Augen führen, Tim, jeden Morgen, ne, stehen die so auf.
Und jeden Abend gehen die so ins Bett, mit dem Gesicht, ja und das ist das ist echt das ist ein hartes Los.
Ja, das sind einfach Jammerlappen und wenn die irgendwas wirklich dringend brauchen, dann ist es kein Sitz im Bundestag, sondern eigentlich eher so so ein sozialer, aber.
Lass es, lass es, Tim. Wir wissen genau, was die brauchen, aber das sagt man so nicht. So.
Sozialarbeiter, die brauchen einfach sozusagen, die müssen einfach wieder in die Gesellschaft reingegriert werden.
Ja, ich habe schon eine Vorstellung, was sie brauchen. Ähm so, wir kommen zu unserem Feedback, aber vorher noch ganz kurz eine Meldung.
Am Samstag, den zwölften, äh, zwölften
zwanzig zwanzig wird es nochmal ein paar RC drei Tickets geben. Wir haben das in der letzten Sendung ja schon angekündigt, dass da wahrscheinlich damit zu rechnen ist, dass dann nochmal ein kleiner Batch kommt. Wie gesagt, die Tickets sind,
kostenlos zu haben und ermöglichen den Eintritt in die.
Communitywelt, die Begegnungsstätte, an der da fleißig gebaut wird, die uns irgendwie ein bisschen ähm wieder äh ein bisschen wiedersehen äh zwischen den Weihnachtsfeiertagen ermöglichen soll.
Ähm außerdem werden gerade weitere Einschränkungen und Lockdownmaßnahmen für
Zeitraum äh diskutiert, was natürlich jetzt auch dieses kleine bisschen vor Ort, was wir mit den Community-Bühnen.
Geplant haben
das Risiko stellt, das heißt, wir werden hier wirklich ähm also wirklich mit einer Veranstaltung zu tun haben, die wirklich so unter den widrigsten und Veranstaltungsfeindlichsten Bedingungen stattfindet, die man sich vorstellen kann, ähm entsprechend, denke ich, muss man wirklich auch seinen Erwartungshorizont da jetzt wirklich dran
anpassen und ähm ja natürlich ist das alles eine eine große,
Scheiße, in der ähm,
in der da jetzt halt versucht wird, noch ein ein zartes Pflänzchen ähm hochzuziehen und ähm ja
hoffen wir, hoffen wir, dass das wenigstens Videostreams ähm erlaubt bleiben.
Das werden sie sicherlich, aber man muss natürlich dann auch davon ausgehen, dass ein gewisser Teil des äh geplanten Veranstaltungsprogramms so auch überhaupt nicht stattfinden kann oder wenn dann eben auch wieder nur unter äh entsprechend erschwerten Bedingungen, also.
Mit einfachen Sachen los, ne? Drei Speakerinnen, die nicht in einer WG wohnen, was macht sie, ne?
Ja. Da können wir also jetzt zusehen, wie äh wie das Risiko äh uns ereilt. Nun, Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Aber sie stirbt.
Es stimmt genau.
Aber zuletzt. So und jetzt kommen wir zum äh kommen wir zum Feedback.
Wir haben oder ich habe in der letzten Sendung einen ausführlichen Kommentar verlesen und äh besprochen, der sich unter anderem auch mit ein paar Themen auseinandergesetzt hat, äh
die nicht im Bereich unserer Expertise liegen. Wir haben das auch anklingen lassen, insbesondere dieses YouTube-Universum gehört nicht zu unserem Fachbereich.
Der Nau-Ost-Konflikt gehört nicht zu unserem Fachbereich und Schwurbler am rechten Rand auch nicht.
Alles nicht unsere Kernkompetenz und wir wurden darauf hingewiesen, dass wir ein paar Aspekte in diesem Kommentar,
kritischer hätten, würdigen oder überprüfen müssen, dafür haben wir auf Twitter ein paar Hinweise bekommen, vielen Dank dafür und insbesondere ein Kommentar von Trolli Schmidlauch, der das nochmal ein bisschen.
Zusammenfasst. Spezifisch geht es dabei einmal um den äh die ganze Sache,
Hendrik M. B. Broder und den Antisemitismusvorwurf gegen dann geht es um die Amadeo und Antonio Stiftung, die der Kommentarautor als Annette Kahane Stiftung bezeichnet hat und ich habe das einfach.
Peilt, ja? Und das ist eine negativ konnotierte Bezeichnung für die Amadeu Antonio Stiftung, wusste ich nicht,
Auch erklärt das. Und ähm dann äh.
Ja, genau dann geht's nochmal um selber. Ich äh verlese den Kommentar von Trolly Schmidt aus. Es beginnt mit dem Thema Henrik M Broder,
Zitat über die Erfinder des Holocausts, die zu seiner Entlassung beim RBB Rundfunk Berlin-Brandenburg geführt hatte, ging nicht etwa direkt an Hendrik M Bruder, sondern
wurde diesem laut eigenen Aussagen von dem eigentlichen Empfänger weitergeleitet. Auch auffällig ist das Framing von Broda und,
der Amadeu Antonio Stiftung und B dieser beiden als entgegengesetzter aber ebenso extreme Pole,
Egal, was man von Zionismus uns insbesondere den mittlerweile in die neue Rechte abgedrifteten Broder hält, ist die Gleichsetzung des Bestrebens eines
Staats für Jüdinnen mit der rassistisch herbei fantasierten Zuschreibung negativer Eigenschaften gegenüber jüdischer Menschen allein aufgrund ihres Seins und ihrer Abstimmung eine
unhaltbare rhetorische Figur.
Abstammung. Du hast Abstimmung gesagt.
Oh, sorry, Abstammung natürlich.
Siehst du, so fremd ist mir dieser Begriff, ne? Meine Seele ist ja rein. Ähm so, dann genau, also ne, hier geht's also spezifisch darum, dass man jetzt nicht sagen kann, dass äh.
Kämpferinnen.
Für gegen Antisemitismus und Rassismus in irgendeiner Form derartig extremistisch sein wie.
Antisemiten.
Okay, kommen wir zur Amadeu Antonio Stiftung. Diese ist sicherlich nicht neutral, die sie als renommierte, da sie als renommierte und langjährige Kämpferin
und Expertinnensammlung zu Rassismus, Antisemitismus und Menschenhass für all diese Themen sicherlich sensibler und aufmerksamer ist als fachfremde Journalistinnen es wären. Das mindert im,
ihre Einschätzung über antisemitische Wurzeln und Figuren in Verschwörungserzählungen nicht eher im Gegenteil.
Und auch hier zeigt der Kommentator ein eindeutiges Framing, in dem er die Amadeu Antonio Stiftung zuerst mit der langjährigen vorsitzenden Kahane,
personifiziert. Die ist nämlich durch ihr langjähriges Engagement zu einer Hassfigur in Rechtsradikalen und antisemitischen Kreisen geworden,
da sie außerdem auch noch Jüdin ist, kursieren, auch zahlreiche eindeutig antisemitische Karikaturen von ihr. Auch stand sie auf diversen sogenannten Todeslisten, zum Beispiel von Franco
A und das sicherlich nicht wegen ihrer Stasivergangenheit, über deren Aufarbeitung ich mir kein Urteil zutraue,
Aus sozialwissenschaftlicher Sicht haben die Aussagen der Stiftung zur Antisemitismus auch nichts, wie vom Kommentarschreiber behauptet,
mit einer Neudefinition durch die angebliche Israel-Lobby zu tun.
Denn Verschwörungserzählung über eine jüdische Rotschild-Elite, die uns alle als Marionettenfäden in der Hand hielte, haben nichts mit Israel zu tun,
und das pflegt ganz klar tradierte antisemitische Erzählungen.
Zu guter Letzt die Aussage, dass Jepsen erst seit zwanzigneunzehn besonders problematisch sei.
Mein Eindruck, der auch durch Korrektiv gestützt wird, ist das Jeppsen schon sehr lange den Zweifel nicht als Werkzeug zur Welterkenntnis nutzt.
Und ihn dort, wo es angebracht ist, einsetzt, sondern ihn als Statussymbol vor sich herträgt. Und aus Prinzip,
überall anwendet. Auch in früheren Videos aus zwanzig, vierzehn, zwanzig fünfzehn, kann da gerne mal die alleinige Tatsache, dass etwas der tradierten Mainstream Erkenntnislage widerspricht,
über ein sonsten eher löchriges Faktenbett hinweg helfen. Das finde ich sehr schön. Diesen gesamten Satz finde ich sehr schön äh formuliert, ja. Der Zweifel als Werkzeug zur Welterkenntnis.
Ähm das finde ich sehr schön formuliert, ne Lob. Ähm Ausdruck, äh Lob für Ausdruck,
Auch war Jepsen bereits zwanzig vierzehn stark in die sogenannten Mahnwachen für den Frieden involviert, in der eine.
Unangenehme Melange aus friedensbewegten Zinskritikern Russland, Freunden und Verschwörungsideologen eine unangenehme Querfront bildeten, die letztendlich auch oftmals die US-amerikanische.
Fett,
oder FED, dass Ostküstenkapital als eigentliche Kriegsursachen zu identifizieren meinte und damit eindeutig strukturell antisemitisch ist. Okay und,
Obwohl deutsche Gerichte sich mit der Bezeichnung antisemit für nach neunzehnhundertfünfundvierzig geborene sehr schwer tun durften, Jepsen und seine Äußerungen bereits zweitausendfünfzehn.
Als klar antisemitisch bezeichnet werden.
Okay, so viel äh eben zu einem Bereich, in dem ich äh zugegebenermaßen offenbar sehr wenig Expertise habe. Ich möchte aber nur sagen, ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich froh, dass wir nicht äh Logbuch ähm,
Naost sind. Aber herzlichen Dank nochmal für äh diese Einordnung des gesamten Themenkomplexes.
Kurze Erläuterung, weil du da grade drüber gestolpert bist, also die US-Amerikanische Fett bezieht sich natürlich auf die Federal.
Federal Reserve gemeint, ne?
Also die Zentralbank, ne? Das ist dann im Prinzip auch wieder alles in diesem selben Geflecht der internationalen, finanziellen Verschwörung und so weiter und das ist halt einfach diese Gesamtgemenge Lage. Ja, also.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr sehr froh, dass wir das jetzt hier auch nochmal so detailliert aufgearbeitet in den Kommentaren finden konnten.
Ja, also da wirklich äh nochmal herzlichen Dank an Trolli Schmidloch hier den den uns offensichtlich fehlenden Hintergrund äh mitgeliefert zu haben.
An der Tag Kahane heißt sie im Übrigen, äh habe ich auch grad.
Mann ey, jetzt habe ich das auch noch falsch.
Ja, ist äh egal. Aber jetzt schon am Korrigieren sind, dann korrigieren wir das mal komplett.
Aber ich ich habe diesen Link auch nicht mitbekommen. Also Amadeo, äh Antonio Stiftung, ist mir sehr wohl äh bekannt, aber ehrlich gesagt hatte ich jetzt äh die Stiftung niemals über ihre Gründerin wahrgenommen und von daher habe ich diese Brücke auch nicht geschlagen.
Also funktioniert das.
Gut, dass wir mit solchen Leuten normalerweise nichts zu tun haben.
Ja, allerdings.
Okay, dann,
haben wir über die Digitalisierung des Robert-Koch-Institutes gesprochen und die dort fehlenden Stellen, da haben wir auch mehreres Feedback zu bekommen. Einmal ähm.
Auch ausführlichen Kommentar wie schräg so die Stellenplanung in diesen öffentlichen Institutionen läuft und dann nochmal von Susanne per E-Mail.
Ähm die und schrieb äh hallo Ines, alle Themen, bis vor circa einem Jahr habe ich,
selbst dort noch als Post-Dock gearbeitet und in so meine icher Raucherpause mit den ITlern über den internen Notstand philosophiert. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr
genau, aber zu der Zeit ungefähr zwanzig neunzehn gab es glaube ich für das ganze Institut fünf bis sieben auf jeden Fall aber unter zehn Stellen für die IT-Infrastruktur
Dabei muss man auch erwähnen,
diese Menschen auch für Dinge wie Rechner, Installation und Updates, Softwareanfragen, Hardwarebedarf, hauseigene Webseite und Intranet oder auch das Bereitstellen von Rechenleistung für diverse Statistikberechnungen und so weiter zuständig sind.
Eine Mitarbeit an Projekten ist also nicht denkbar.
Allein das dürfte sie schon vollkommen auslasten. Damals stand auch grade ein Institut weites Update auf eine neue Windows-Version an. Okay, das äh erledigt jede Organisation.
Dass das Ende einer jeden Organisation, das muss man einfach sagen so. Und der Mitarbeiter,
mit dem ich damals sprach, meinte, dass es sich um Monate hinziehen würde, um mal zwischenzeitlich eigentlich alle Rechner ausschalten müsste, die noch nicht geupdatet sind, weil die alte Version nicht mehr unterstützt wird.
Der Abgrund ist also tief. Außerdem weiß ich, dass ungefähr zur selben Zeit die Infrastruktur durch ein externes Unternehmen evaluiert wurde. Das Endergebnis, es fehlen mindestens einhundert Stellen im IT-Bereich, die vier Stellen
Sind also wirklich lächerlich. Tatsächlich wundert mich das aber nicht
intern existiert nämlich die Problematik, dass es einen hohen Druck gibt, Stellen im Wissenschaftsbereich zu schaffen. Wenn also Geld fließt, dann chronisch
immer zu wenig in der Infrastruktur. In der Rechtsabteilung in Finanzabteilung sieht es entsprechend ähnlich düster aus.
Was teilweise Projekte um Monate oder gar Jahre verzögert und zum Beispiel auch beim Datenschutz große Probleme bereitet. Ein weiteres Problem ist natürlich auch die Kunst, Konkurrenzfähigkeit der,
Löhner, es ist zweifelhaft, dass man am RKI mit der Industrie mithalten kann. Immerhin ist eben IT,
wahrscheinlich nicht wissenschaftliche Arbeit und damit eher bei E elf angesiedelt. E elf ist dann hier äh TV ÖD, ne.
Tarifvertrag für den öffentlichen Dienst wo es so Gehälterstufen gibt und elf ist glaube ich dann nicht so der.
Nicht so die Basis für äh Wohlstand äh folgender Generation.
Okay.
Äh
anyway, ich dachte, ich trage meine Bits and Pieces mal bei. Wie gesagt, wir haben da viele Klagen aus diesem Bereich und nochmal eine andere Schilderung, wo es dann äh mit Stellen eher nicht von der äh nicht in die Forschung, sondern eher in die Verwaltung ging, aber ja
halten wir fest ähm.
Das Vorurteil scheint sich zu bestätigen, dass ähm öffentliche Einrichtungen von einer äh mangelnden Dynamik,
geprägt sind.
In den Kommentaren gibt's dann
dazu auch noch von Annika auch noch eine längere ähm Schilderung, wie das so mit diesen ganzen Stellenausschreibungen funktioniert und äh es ist nicht dieselbe,
aber so im Prinzip auch hier dasselbe Drama, da gibt's dann externe Firmen, die beauftragt werden, äh das alles zu analysieren, die machen einen Vorschlag und am Ende kam dann irgendwie auch nur vier Stellen bei raus und äh äh,
es hat einfach alles sehr lange gedauert,
und am Ende hat wahrscheinlich nur diese externe Firma irgendein Geld verdient und hätte man die Kohle, die man für diese Firma, für die Analyse gebraucht hätte, einfach für die Stellen aufgewendet, wäre äh schon alles gut gewesen.
Ein weiterer äh Kommentar erreichte uns noch zu dem Thema der Kontaktverfolgung von Le.
Da heißt es ein kleiner Einblick zur Kontaktnachverfolgung. Ich bin Corona,
positiv, mich hat danach ein paar Tagen das Gesundheitsamt angerufen und mir nach einem vielleicht zwei minütigen Telefonat eine Mail geschickt. An diese sehr kurze Mail war ein Excelsheet angehängt,
Ein schlicht formatiertes Excel-Sheet. Hier musste ich dann Name, Adresse, Geburtsdatum
Mailadresse, Telefonnummer A der Beziehung, Ort und Zeit, Kontakt et cetera
inklusive aller meiner engen und nicht engen Kontakte der letzten Tage eintragen. Es gab nirgends einen Hinweis zum Datenschutz oder weitere Erklärungen, dann musste ich meine Kontakte logo unverschlüssel per Mail dem Gesundheitsamt wieder zurückschicken,
das ist schon sehr bitter alles. Ich finde, ich finde selbstverständlich, dass meine paar Kontakte und,
ich in Isolation und Quarantäne sind, aber ein miesformatiertes Unkommentiertes, unverschlüsseltes Excel steht, führt bei mir erstmal zu Schnappatmung und ich kriege dank Corona eh schon schlecht Luft,
Ja, also solche solche Berichte finden sich vielfältig im im im Netz. Also immer die Storys mit so ich äh habe mir Corona eingefangen und hier ist meine Geschichte mit der Corona-Warn-App und oder dem Gesundheitsamt, da äh ist,
glaube ich auch schon alles geschildert worden, was irgendwie schiefgehen kann.
Ist schwierig hier wieder den den Finger äh irgendwo ähm hinzuzeigen. Sicherlich kann man äh ihn in die Wunde legen. Äh.
Grade die Gesundheitsämter, ich hatte auch bei UKW auch schon mal so eine.
Sendung, über so ein Projekt, was aus einem dieser hervorgegangen ist, die er dann auch gerade versucht haben, gerade für diese Kontaktverfolgung dann einfach sorgflos
webbasierte Workflows zu machen, ne, sowohl
intern, um das nachzureichen und ich glaube auch für solche äh Dateneinsammlung kann man alles besser machen, aber derzeit ist es halt einfach ein Wildwuchs.
Trifft hier auch ähm in dieser ganzen Pandemie und das merkt man jetzt auch in dieser ganzen Diskussion um den Lockdown.
Etwas, was ansonsten vielleicht eher ein Vorteil ist, nämlich unsere föderale Struktur mit den großen Kompetenzen, die dann Länder und teilweise auch Gemeinden haben,
nicht unbedingt immer alles von Vorteil.
Damit will ich jetzt nicht sagen, das muss alles zwangsläufig zentralisiert werden und nur bundesstaatlich organisiert werden, das nicht so, aber es muss auch klar sein, dass es äh solche Probleme nach sich ziehen kann. Und,
die überall mir immer wieder hängende Frage von wie kann es denn sein, dass wir so eine bekloppte Gesamt-Digitalinfrastruktur haben?
Das ist etwas, was meiner Meinung nach langfristig äh auf Bundesebene organisiert werden müsste, dass man auf der einen Seite,
muss nicht vielleicht gleich ein eigenes Ministerium sein, aber zumindest ein sehr hoch,
angelegte Struktur hat. Diese ganze digitale Planung,
für alle Ministerien, für alle Behörden und so weiter zumindest soweit unter ein Dach zu bringen, dass halt mal besser koordiniert wird. Ich.
Idee wie man das machen könnte, Tim.
Könnte eine Staatsministerin für Digitalisierung direkt bei der Kanzlerin aufhängen und dann könnte man diese Stelle besetzen mit mit Dorothee Bär. Das das müsste das Problem doch eigentlich lösen.
Ja, tut's aber offensichtlich nicht, weil den Fall haben wir ja schon und ähm ich äh ich sehe es eher.
Vielleicht braucht ihr noch eine zweite Stelle. Vielleicht braucht ihr mehr Stellen. Dann müsst ihr die beantragen natürlich, ne? Also vorbehaltlich einer Prüfung.
Also ich bin ja nun kein kein Politikwissenschaftler und habe relativ wenig äh um nicht zu sagen, überhaupt gar keine Erfahrung im politischen Betrieb. Nur aus meiner.
Eher technisch geprägten Sicht würde ich sagen, es müsste so etwas geben wie so ein Digital,
Privileg, was so ähnlich gehandhabt wird, wie das derzeit mit Geld ist. Ja, so ein Finanzministerium kann,
irgendwie dazwischen pfuschen, weil wofür keine Kohle da ist, das findet dann einfach nicht statt. Und wenn es äh ein digitales Ministerium gibt, was halt sagen kann, ach ihr plant hier irgendwelche Großprojekte,
Ihr wollt hierfür
tralala äh neue Organisation Gesundheitsämter und so weiter. Ihr wollt da was machen?
Dann sind hier die Prozesse, wie wir das Ganze vereinheitlichen und wir können immer schauen,
da haben wir doch schon was und da ist auch das für zuständig und hier wird die gemeinsame Infrastruktur geplant, nicht nur was so die Sicherheit betrifft mit BSI, sondern eben auch einfach die sonstigen funktionalen Einheiten,
das muss nicht zwangsläufig dann automatisch besser funktionieren, aber all das nicht zu machen
führt eben zu diesen zahlreichen Insellösungen, die dann alle vor sich hinschmoren und äh auch nicht mehr richtig supportet werden. Wir hatten das äh schon tausendfach mit DE Mail und all diesen ganzen anderen
und äh hier die dieses Anwaltspostfach und so, wo man sie einfach immer wieder fragt, sag mal,
habt ihr da keine Kompetenz und die Antwort natürlich ist, so nein, haben wir nicht, weil wir sind irgendwie hier, dass Ministerium für Justiz und das ist halt einfach nicht unsere Kernkompetenz,
Und diese Kompetenz müsste eben zentral in der Bundesregierung einfach verankert werden, dass man sagen kann, so okay
ja, ihr habt alle das Problem, dass Dinge digitalisiert werden müssen, genauso wie alles mit Geld versorgt werden muss, wie wie koordinieren das mal? Wir bauen auch Projekte auf, wir stellen auch, was weiß ich, sicher, dass Open-Source
Systeme, auf die wir dann setzen wollen, dann auch entsprechend am Leben erhalten werden, mitfinanziert werden, aufgebaut werden, vielleicht überhaupt auch erstmal gestartet werden. Ähm ja und kritische Infrastruktur äh da auch ansetzen kann.
Und dann kann das langfristig ein ein Weg sein. Wirklich alle Probleme lösen, aber so wie es jetzt ist, wird halt einfach überhaupt gar kein Problem gelöst.
Du hast das gerade digital Privileg genannt. Ich glaube, dass äh der richtige Begriff wäre digital vorbehalt. Also so eine Art, ne, das muss ist zustimmungspflichtig.
Und ähm also eine hätte quasi Kapitänz und ich habe da mal gedacht so, oh Digitalformbehalt, hat das eigentlich schon mal jemand gefordert? Ja, der Bundesverband äh digitaler Wirtschaft, zum Beispiel hat das ähm,
gefordert. Spezifisch das was du gerade sagst ja? Also sämtliche Gesetzesvorhaben die die digitale Wirtschaft betreffen,
bei der designierten Digitalministerin Doro DB,
äh die äh bekannte Fußballtorwartin. Nein, ähm Dorothee.
Bär äh laufen müssen und ähm.
Natürlich du hättest das jetzt ja noch ausgeweitet äh auf eben auch die äh Digitalisierung von Verwaltung und äh Government.
Ja, schön wär's. Also da halten wir auch das das wäre das könnte man auch so machen. Wir haben noch ein ein Feedback äh zum Thema der Gesichtserkennung und zwar hatte ich kurz darüber gesprochen, über die äh von André Meister war das, glaube ich, die Meldung bei Netz-Boutique org.
Darauf hinwies, dass die
Gesichtserkennungssysteme jetzt so geringe Fehlerquoten nur noch haben, auch wenn siebzig Prozent des Gesichts äh bedeckt ist. Die Meldung habe ich irgendwie kurz vorm Podcast gelesen, habe mich dann gewundert, dass da nicht zwei Fehlerquoten angegeben sind. Nämlich die.
Positives und Fords Negatives.
Und das hat uns Andrea, Andreas erklärt, Andreas, kurzer Hinweis bezüglich der Fehlerquote bei der Sicht Gesichtserkennung. Die Fünf-Prozent-Fehlerquote waren hier die falsch Negativen.
Wenn man die falsch Positiven auf null Komma null null null ein Prozent fixiert, also einen von einhunderttausend. Im Bild, das bei Netzbild Org zitiert wurde, ist das beschriftet mit,
FMA at FMA Equals zero point zero zero zero one. Also.
Ja, also genau, du kannst ja quasi die im Prinzip.
Fein bestimmen, ja, da kannst du jetzt dir aussuchen und wenn du den einen fixierst, auf einen allgemeingültigen Wert, dann ergibt sich der andere auf der Basis automatisch und deswegen können die dann eben sagen, fünf Prozent.
Weil eben der andere fix gesetzt ist auf diese null Komma null ein Prozent.
Walter, es besteht ein Trade-Off zwischen falsch-negativen und falsch positiven und letztere kann man einfach immer auf null reduzieren, indem man alles ablehnt.
Außerdem möchte man am liebsten eine einzelne Kennziffer für den Vergleich von Systemen, daher ist es nicht ungewöhnlich, die falsch Positiven,
auf ein akzeptabel niedriges Niveau zu fixieren und dann einfach nur noch die falsch-negativen zu vergleichen.
Vielen Dank für äh diese Erläuterung. Und damit sind wir mit dem Feedback durch und können,
zu den anderen schlechten Nachrichten kommen?
Wobei so schlecht sind die jetzt gar nicht. Also wir haben ja hier also mal gucken, wie schlecht die sind. Gehen wir gehen wir der Reihe nach durch. Also als erstes ist die äh Terrorist Content Online Regulation,
hat jetzt den Trilog abgeschlossen und ähm also der diese Verhandlung zwischen Parlament.
Und Kommission und da gibt es vier entscheidende Ergebnisse.
Patrick, den wir hier ja auch schon zu Besuch hatten. Äh der äh in dem äh bei dieser bei diesem Trilog eben der Schattenberichterstatter der grünen Fraktion war, sagt.
Pflicht zum Einsatz von Uploadfiltern ist jetzt eindeutig ausgeschlossen. Das ist ein großes Ding. Wir wissen, äh Patrick hat hier viel darüber gesprochen. Thomas Lohninger hat hier viel darüber gesprochen, dass es hier,
haarscharf im Raum stand, dass wir das eben die zweite äh EU-Gesetzgebung mit Upload-Filtern bekommen hätten.
Aber das Parlament hat an seiner Position festgehalten, dass, und zwar jetzt so krass über welche Begriffe die sich ähm,
ähm auseinandersetzen, dass eben keine proaktiven Maßnahmen vorgeschrieben werden, sondern spezifische Maßnahmen
Und diese spezifischen Maßnahmen müssen nicht notwendigerweise automatischer Natur sein, sondern lediglich angemessen. Ne, also wenn du sagst, es muss proaktiv sein. Klar, dann heißt das muss aktiv.
Von sich initiativ sein und wenn du aber sagst, sie müssen spezifisch und angemessen sein.
Dann lässt sich daraus eben nicht lassen sich daraus auch andere Maßnahmen als Upload-Filter.
Ableiten. Ähm zum Beispiel ein großes Moderationsteam.
Kann, das kann diese Anforderung erfüllen. Also Upload-Filterpflicht, zumindest abgewendet. Was nicht heißt, dass nicht große Plattformen trotzdem Uploadfilter verwenden.
Aber kleine Plattformen haben zumindest eine Alternative.
Genau, genau. Dann es gibt eine kurze Löschfrist, ja, die ist krass, ja. Anbieter müssen deutlich schneller auf äh Entfernungsanordnungen reagieren als vorher. Ähm und zwar binnen einer Stunde,
Ähm da gibt es aber dann Ausnahmen für kleine und nicht-kommerzielle ähm Plattformen.
Wenn du also jetzt irgendwie eine Privatperson bist oder ein Communityprojekt. Ähm.
Kurz nochmal zu dieser Löschfrist. Das gilt eben für Löschanforderungen und die sind auch grenzüberschreitend möglich, ne? Das,
Beispiel, was wir hier mal hatten, war das dann im Prinzip ähm
ja, was weiß ich, Orban in ganz Europa, irgendwelche Sachen äh löschen lassen kann. Allerdings kann ein Land einer solchen Anordnung widersprechen
Und es gibt einen präzisen Anfechtungsweg für die betroffenen Parteien, um hier diesem Mittel ähm,
oder einem Missbrauch dieses Mittels auch einen Rechtsweg entgegenzusetzen. Das klingt also auch danach, dass hier ein bisschen Ratio.
Ähm eingekehrt ist. Ähm und jetzt gibt's natürlich das große Thema ne, was musst du alles machen.
Um eben Sanktionen auszuweichen, weil es wird ja trotzdem es werden ja trotzdem Sachen schiefgehen. Ne, und dann musst du ja letztendlich so, also Sachen schiefgehen im Sinne von, da ist dann terroristischer Inhalt länger online geblieben, wurde und so weiter.
Aber damit du eben in dem Fall nicht sanktioniert wirst, musst du eine Reihe an Vorkehrungen treffen. Zum Beispiel müssen deine Nutzungsbedingungen,
ausdrücklich die Verbreitung terroristischer Inhalte verbieten, weil wir ja wissen, Terroristen halten sich ein wenig, aber die Nutzungsbedingungen sind heilig.
Und du musst ein äh gesetzlichen Vertreter benennen,
Ähm und dann gibt's eben Geldstrafen, wenn das nicht der Fall ist, darüber entscheiden aber dann die EU-Länder selbst, bei systematischen oder anhaltenden Verstößen, anhaltenden Verstößen, können da bis zu vier Prozent des Jahresumsatzes an Strafe
anfallen. So.
Aber jetzt gibt's eben diese Ausnahmen für Anbieter, die aus technischen oder betrieblichen Gründen einer Löschanordnung nicht innerhalb von einer Stunde nachkommen können, zum Beispiel private Webseitenbetreiber zur Nachtzeit, äh die sind dann eben nicht von von Geldstrafen.
Da sind wir gerade nochmal davongekommen.
Wie auch wir müssen wahrscheinlich jetzt hier leider, tut uns leid, ne? Aber wir müssen unsere Nutzungsbedingungen müssen jetzt eben ausdrücklich die Verbreitung terroristischer Inhalte verbieten, weil, na, wir wissen,
Nutzungsbedingungen sind selbst terroristunheilig.
Das ist also, ich meine, da muss man wirklich sagen, also diese ganze Terror Regulation, Terrice Online Content Regulation. Das war ja ein großer Kopfschmerz, ne? Und.
Tja, hier sieht man eben, okay, es gab jetzt hier eben Bemühungen,
da das Schlimmste zu verhindern und ich lese das jetzt mal so, dass das hier gelungen ist, ne? Patrick Breyer ist natürlich nicht zufrieden. Ähm nicht, also Entschuldigung, natürlich nicht vollständig zufrieden, aber an den entscheidenden Punkten,
sind hier, so scheint es, wichtige Weichenstellungen.
Ähm gesetzt worden, um so die Vollkatastrophe zu verhindern. Immerhin.
Und wenn so eine Vollkatastrophe verhindert wird, dann liegt das ja daran, dass es,
Sachverständige, Diskussion zu diesen Vorhaben gibt, dass sich eben,
Viele Menschen einbringen, die ein bisschen mehr darüber nachdenken, als da muss man jetzt endlich mal was tun und es kann ja nicht sein. Und das ist ja in der Demokratie ein sehr wichtiger Teil der des Gesetzgebungsprozesses.
Und gerade in in Deutschland nicht nur in Deutschland.
Bemängeln wir ja regelmäßig, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Wenn wir uns so.
Gesetzgebungsprozess anschauen. Ähm gibt's denn irgendwie so einen Referentinnentwurf? Der wird dann irgendwann letztendlich von der Regierung in das Parlament herab äh gereicht, da die ähm Regierung.
Tateinheit mit der ähm mit den größten Fraktionen oder der großen Koalition.
Agiert sind, ab diesem Moment keine großartigen Veränderungen mehr zu erwarten. Ich war ja selber schon
mehrere Male als Sachverständiger, Vertreter des Chaos, Computerclubs in solchen
Bundestagsausschussanhörungen, na, da gehst du dann in was weiß ich, zum Beispiel in den Innenausschuss und sagst, pass mal auf, an dem, was hier vorliegt, ist das und das und das,
ja vielleicht Unsinn, das und das verbesserungswürdig und hier sind die Empfehlungen, wie man da noch was dran machen könnte. Und dann wird gesagt,
danke, vielen Dank. Äh spannend, spannend, was sie hier erzählt haben. Leider sind sie aber der Sachverständige der Opposition und wir haben jetzt keine Zeit mehr.
Insofern ähm danke tschüss. So. Äh bessere Möglichkeiten der Einflussnahme hast du.
Bevor dieser Referentenentwurf als Gesetz als Formulierungshilfe oder wie auch immer als Gesetzesvorschlag von der Regierung in das Parlament herabgereicht wird, nämlich wenn.
Die Ministerien nach ähm Kommentaren fragen und das war jetzt bei zwei Gesetzen der Fall, insbesondere,
IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null, was ja hier auch seit Monaten diskutiert wird in in Deutschland, dann kommt immer mal wieder irgendwie so ein Entwurf, der den hat dann irgendjemand, das ist dann so ein Referentinnentwurf, wo man mal draufguck,
kann. Und den haben sie jetzt,
Aber es war immer so die Frage, ne, sollen wir den jetzt kommentieren oder nicht? Wann wann werden jetzt mal hier Verbände und Zivilgesellschaft gebeten, weil das eben ein ein Moving Target ist, so ein Gesetz, so ein Referentenentwurf, solange da nichts.
Äh solange da nichts klar ist beim BND-Gesetz war's ja ähnlich, ne. Da liegt dann mal der Entwurf, dann wird kommentiert und dann wird gesagt, ja Entschuldigung, also äh das bezieht sich auf einen veralteten Entwurf. Wir machen ja was ganz anderes inzwischen, ja. Also dieser Prozess
ist ähm wirklich katastrophal und,
Das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null muss man ja sagen, liegt beim Innenministerium, was sowieso schon mal immer ein schlechtes Zeichen ist. Und da würde ich.
Mal in Erinnerung rufen an dieser Stelle. Eine kleine Äußerung über das Selbstverständnis und das Arbeitsverständnis von Horst Seehofer, die wir an dieser Stelle vielleicht mal kurz,
einspielen könnt, Tim. Ne, der äußert sich Horst Seehofer vor Journalistinnen über ähm,
Ein Gesetzes Gesetzgebungsvorhaben und wie er es geschafft hat, dass ohne große Diskussion ähm vielleicht,
einzubringen. Und er redet da wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu äh offen darüber, wie man denn als Innenminister.
Oder als Innenministerium so ein Gesetz reinkriegt und was er von der Beteiligung.
Der Zivilgesellschaft hält.
So und damit niemand unzulässig das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null in Frage stellt ähm,
wurde dieser, wurde ein ähm Referentenentwurf davon veröffentlicht und,
ähm den Verbänden, den interessierten Verbänden eine Frist von vier Tagen gegeben.
Diesen Gesetzesentwurf zu kommentieren. Zweiundneunzig Seiten, ja? Also.
Etwas unter fünfundzwanzig Seiten pro Tag, sollte ja zu schaffen sein, dass du auf Zuruf ohne vorherige Ankündigung und Vorbereitung mal eben so ein Referentenentwurf
kommentierst, ja, mit einer schriftlichen Stellungnahme an das Bundesministerium für Inneres und Heimat, kein Thema. Es gab natürlich dann,
Protest gegen diese vier Tagesfrist, die wurde dann korrigiert großzügig. Auf sieben Tage, ja?
Sieben Tage zum Einreichen von Stellungnahmen.
Und dann haben die am neunten Dezember selber, also an dem Tag selbst, wo sie, den sie als Deadline gesetzt haben, liegte dann,
Ein bereits veränderter äh neuer Referentenentwurf mitstand vom neunten Dezember, der jetzt einhundertacht statt zweiundneunzig Seiten lang ist und umfassende Veränderungen und Erweiterungen hatte.
Ja? Und der der war quasi, den hatten die schon in der Hinterhand.
Den haben die aber auch noch nicht mal selber veröffentlicht, sondern der liegt über einen Verband, der da irgendwie die Finger dran bekommen hat. Und das zeigt einfach nur, weißt du, wie viel Wert die darauf legen, dass sich da jemand einbringt? Nämlich überhaupt nicht,
Diese knappe Fristsetzung ist natürlich eine Unverschämtheit. An dem Ding schon weiterzuarbeiten, ohne überhaupt das Feedback abgewartet zu haben, ist eine Frechheit. Und.
Also ich kann gar nicht sagen, wie wie katastrophal ich das finde, ja? Und wir haben als Chaos-Computer-Club da jetzt auch nochmal eine.
Eine eine Meldung zu abgegeben haben, hat gesagt, also eine das das geht so nicht und das ist einfach nur das zeigt halt eine absolute Verachtung,
gegenüber den demokratischen Beteiligungsprozessen. Wir fordern also jetzt eine Mindestfristen für solche Beteiligung und Beratungen, weil.
Dass ja nicht, also abgesehen davon, dass das also dieser
Teil, der da jetzt stattfindet, ne? Wir haben einen Referentenentwurf und die Verbände dürfen äh kommentieren. Das ist kein ähm vorgegebener
etablierter Prozess, der irgendwo in der Verfassung steht oder so, sondern machen die.
Auch nur aus Großzügigkeit. Entsprechend kannst du dich da jetzt noch nicht mal beschweren. Das das, weil du eigentlich froh sein kannst, dass du überhaupt dich nach deiner Meinung fragen und dich nicht irgendwie ähm.
Später dann am langen Arm in den Ausschüssen verhungern lassen. Aber das ist wirklich, also das ist wirklich äh wirklich schlimm, ne? Und wir, ich meine, wir reden hier von einem wichtigen
gesetzt, ja, in einem digitalen Entwicklungsland, äh das wir ja sind. Ähm gleichzeitig hat das alte IT-Sicherheitsgesetz
eine Evaluation nach vier Jahren,
vorgesehen und diese diese vier Jahre sind seit sechzehn Monaten um. Ja, also das es wäre eigentlich Aufgabe des BMI gewesen, das existierende IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zu evaluieren und zwar vor einem Jahr schon, spätestens und,
auf dieser Basis vielleicht nun ein IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null zu schreiben. Aber auf diese Evaluation des IT-Sicherheitsgesetz eins null haben sie verzichtet. Sie verzichten,
auf ähm kompetenten Rat, ja, oder versuchen den auszustechen. Ähm.
Hier die äh AGritis, die ja auch schon in Lokbuch-Netzpolitik zu Gast war, hat das Treffen als ähm den ausgestreckten Mittelfinger bezeichnet, was da passiert und also ich.
Du fragst dich wirklich, also das ist aus, also,
warum. Ja, die, also du du hast ja nun mal jetzt hier wirklich Expertin in den in den kritischen Infrastrukturen, Expertin in der IT-Sicherheit, Chaos, Computerclubs, die wir nun wirklich, sagen wir mal,
eines kann man dem Chaos-Computerclub ja nun nicht nachsagen und das wäre Inkompetenz in Fragen der IT-Sicherheit. Ja, dass also vieles kann man uns nachsagen, aber das nun mal nicht
und diesen kostenlosen Rat ja von ehrenamtlich Engagierten, den will man doch haben,
Ich verstehe, also aber so ein so ein so ein Egomaniac, wie dieser Seehofer, denkt, denkt dann halt, das wäre unzulässiges, infrage stellen, der Notwendigkeiten und das ist wirklich, also.
Das finde ich schockierend, das ist der Mann ist eine einzige Katastrophe.
Offensichtlich wollen sie diesen Rat nicht haben. So, weil sie, weil sie wissen, was dieser Rat dann äh rüberbringen wird, nämlich dass es irgendwie geht.
Ja, aber weißt du, Menschen, die Ignoranz für Stärke halten, das sind halt, das sind wirklich die Schwächsten.
Die frustrierten sind das, ne?
Seehofer ist auch kein glücklicher Mensch, ne? Das muss man sich jetzt echt nicht äh einbilden, dass dass der irgendwie zufrieden wäre. Aber okay, das äh sein privates Problem. Es wird nur halt zu unserem, wenn der Mann unser Innenminister ist.
Bei der TKG-Novelle, Telekommunikationsgesetznovelle.
Ähm die wenn ich mich täusche, kommt die nicht vom ähm Innenministerium, sondern vom Wirtschaftsministerium, weil das ja äh hauptsächlich Regulierung ist. Ich muss hier mal kurz gucken. Ja, das müsste bitter zum Story. Nee.
Justizministerium ist da auch dran beteiligt. Okay, also letztendlich das Telekommunikationsgesetz soll novelliert werden und da wurden jetzt, da wird das Ganze noch besser gemacht.
Da äh der Entwurf ist vierhundertfünfzig Seiten stark und die Vertreter von Wirtschaft und Zivilgesellschaft kriegen.
Zwei Tage Zeit um den zu diskutieren oder zu kommentieren.
In der Zeit kann man's ja noch nicht mal durchlesen.
Wird auf jeden Fall anstrengend, ne? Wird jetzt sagen die natürlich.
Aber unsere Frontgröße war doch achtzehn Punkt.
Ich glaube, deren Punkt ist eher so, weißt du, die die sagen halt so, na ja, pass mal auf, wir mussten erstmal vierhundertfünfzig Seiten schreiben. Wenn wir jetzt auf einmal vierhundertfünfzig Seiten Kommentare dazu kriegen, dann müssen wir die ja alle lesen. Da geht der geht die ja gar nicht.
Ne? Und äh jetzt ist es natürlich auch weiterhin so.
Gerade so eine TKG-Novelle, da geht's zum Beispiel um die Vertragslaufzeit. Ja, wir haben ja festgehalten oder wir haben ja regelmäßig diskutiert. Einer der entscheidenden Faktoren, die dazu führen, dass in Deutschland die ähm Mobilfunk,
Tarife dann doch relativ teuer sind, sind die langen Vertragslaufzeiten. Die nämlich einfach diesen Preisdruck durch Konkurrenz.
Unter den Anbietern verlangsamen, ja? Wenn die Vertragslaufzeit nur ein Jahr ist, dann guckst du dich eben jedes Jahr nach einem neuen Vertrag um, mit anderen Worten, die haben für einen Anbieter stehen
spätestens nach einem Jahr oder spätestens nach zwei Jahren im Prinzip
alle Verträge wieder zur Disposition und der muss sich bemühen, Konkurrent äh konkurrenzfähig zu bleiben, während das eben.
Wenn es zwei Jahre sind, ist es eben fast vier Jahre, bis alle Verträge wieder zur Disposition gestanden haben. So, jetzt wird in diesem TKG-Nove Gesetz wird gesagt, ja also.
Man kann jetzt irgendwie die zwei Jahre behalten, ja? Anbieter müssen aber auch Verträge mit nur einem Jahr anbieten.
Aber wenn du einen mit nur einem Jahr machst, dann dann darf der nur höchstens fünfundzwanzig Prozent teurer sein. Ist auch irgendwie so,
Danke. Stark, oder?
Er darf nicht mehr als fünfundzwanzig Prozent teurer sein. Also er darf auch noch teurer sein, weil er ja nur ein Jahr ist. Super.
Ja. Ja, er darf teurer sein. Ja, aber nur, nur ein Viertel.
So
Witze,
Totaler Witz, also nur weil, aber wahrscheinlich haben die sie nämlich gesagt, nee und musst den gleichen Vertrag auch mit mit einiger Laufzeit anbieten und dann haben die dann haben die Anbieter gesagt, ja alles klar, dann machen wir halt ein Jahr, aber doppelt so teuer,
So, du kannst auch nur ein Jahr Vertragsbindung haben, musst halt das Doppelte bezahlen. Und da wird jetzt sagen so, nee, nee. Dafür, dass du den Vertrag nach einem Jahr kündigen.
Können möchtest, darfst du höchstens fünfundzwanzig Prozent mehr pro Monat bezahlen. Alles andere.
Ist eben nicht mehr zu rechtfertigen. Also komm, da kannst du doch vergessen, ja? Was sie abschaffen wollen, ist das Nebenkostenprivileg, das klingt mir erstmal ganz sinnvoll.
Weil nämlich Wohnungsunternehmen, Hausbesitzer, ähm,
Kabelnetzbetreiber, den Kabel-TV-Anschluss über die Mietnebenkosten abrechnen können. Und das wiederum hat äh wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, in vielen Wohnungen, den Aspekt.
Dass du potentiell gar nicht sagen kannst, du willst den Mist nicht haben.
Und da äh sind natürlich dann die Kabelnetzbetreiber unglücklich, weil die natürlich das schön finden, wenn sie ähm eben über die,
über über dieses Nebenkosten Privileg so 'ne Cashcow haben, weil da dadurch sagen die im Prinzip den Vermietern, ey, voll geil, ne? Wir machen hier dein ganzes Haus voll mit Kabel TV und müssen eh deine Mieter zahlen
Ja, du hast quasi das Privileg, diesen deine Kosten für den Kabelanschluss einfach von deinen Mietern zahlst und das ist doch eine Spitzensache.
Ne? Und dann ähm dadurch haben aber dann die Leute, die diesen mit diesem blöden Kabelanschluss dann da sitzen und den ganzen Scheiß gucken müssen,
können halt nicht sagen, sie wollen das nicht haben. Also da da scheint noch irgendwie ähm was zu sein. Interessanterweise aber auch hier,
kritisieren die Verbände Klaus Landefeld haben wir hier schon oft erwähnt auch zu Gast gehabt der letzten Sendung erst nochmal gewürdigt sagt eben auch es geht jetzt nur noch darum die Gesetze noch in diesem Jahr durchs Kabinett zu bringen. Das ist Ausdruck bloßer,
gesetzgeberischer und politischer Hilflosigkeit wie hier vor dem Ende der Legislaturperiode agiert wird,
der Breko, ähm äh Breitbandkommunikationsverband äh.
Ohne eine angemessene Beteiligung der Branche durchzuwinken, halten wir für sehr kritisch.
Ähm.
Einer Branchen beteiligt. Es ist darf man immer, wir versuchen das ja hier vorsichtig zu würdigen. Natürlich ist es sinnvoll, bevor man eine Branche reguliert, auch deren Meinung dazu zu hören. Aber natürlich ist es auch wichtig, mehr als nur die Meinung der Branche zu hören.
Anke Domscheid auch in Lockbuch schon zu Gast gewesen, ne? Netzpolitisch der Linkspartei.
Was für eine haarströmende Missachtung demokratischer Prozesse. Weder Fachleute der Verbände, noch das Parlament können sich in wenigen Tagen ein hinreichendes Bild machen, das ist eine bodenlose Frechheit. Und das Krasse ist, ähm sie hat.
Ne, sie hatte sehr Recht mit diesem Satz, aber es gibt nichts, was die zwingt.
Das nicht so zu machen, es gibt ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal was, was denen vorschreibt, überhaupt für ihre ähm.
Referentenentwürfe, irgendwelche Kommentierungsmöglichkeiten anzubieten. Also selbst diese Frechheit, da sind wir noch, hängen wir noch an deren Gnade. Und das ist, denke ich, ein Missstand, der ähm,
aufgeräumt werden muss.
Weiß gar nicht, was sie wollten, die Pläne zur Zerstörung ihres Planeten waren doch ähm mehrere Jahre irgendwie auf einem anderen Planeten vor. Also, wenn wir da nichts dafür.
Ich habe als, wir haben ja jetzt Chaos, Computerclub, diese Stellungnahme dann auch nochmal an das BMI geschickt und ähm an den an den Innenausschuss. Also hier nochmal zum ähm nicht zur TKG-Novelle, sondern zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Haben wir auch nochmal betont, dass wir unter,
angemessenen Rahmenbedingungen sehr gerne bereit sind, ehrenamtlich unsere Expertise zu diesem Thema einzubringen, ja?
Das war eine ist als Drohung verstanden worden.
Jetzt werden sie mal nicht frech. Nein, ich habe eine sehr höfliche E-Mail geschrieben. Mit vorzüglicher Hochachtung habe ich dir geschrieben.
Trotzdem, trotzdem als Drogen verstanden worden.
Ja, Gesetzesnovellen, das scheint so ein bisschen das Thema äh jetzt zum Ende des Jahres zu sein. Alle wollen das jetzt hier nochmal schnell äh fertig kriegen.
Und natürlich hat es auch immer was mit Fristen und Umsetzungsfristen zu tun. Da muss dann schnell, schnell, schnell nochmal was umgesetzt werden,
unter anderem halt auch EU-Richtlinien. So ist es jetzt äh auch mit einer.
EU-Richtlinie von zwanzigneunzehn, die sich auf den Warenkauf bezieht.
Und die äh vorhat, die Verbraucherrechte zu stärken.
Unter anderem im Bereich von Waren mit, wie das so schön heißt, digitalen Elementen,
Und dort gibt es jetzt einen entsprechenden Referentenentwurf des Bundesministeriums äh der Justiz.
Ähm wo halt äh eben für diese Waren, also was sind die Ware mit digitalen Elementen, das sind alles äh Computer, ne, Smartphones, Smart.
Watches, äh all diese ganzen smarten Haushaltsgeräte, die jetzt mit einem reden wollen vom Kühlschrank bis zum äh Saugroboter et cetera PP, aber auch so Spielekonsolen, also im Prinzip eigentlich alles, was,
digitale Elemente enthält, sprich wo ein Computer dran ist.
Und hier geht's halt dann äh vor allem um diese Update-Pflicht. Wir hatten ja hier auch schon mehrfach dadrüber gesprochen. Gerade im Hinblick auf Security, dass halt ein Gerät, was eben,
Computer enthält und dann später keine Softwareupdates mehr erhält, irgendwann einfach zwangsläufig der ja.
Dem Angriff aus dem Netz
äh preisgegeben ist. Das muss nicht unbedingt das Internet sein, sondern das kann natürlich auch lokale Netzwerke sein, Bluetooth, WLAN, all diese ganzen Einfallspunkte und da ja diese Geräte heutzutage nicht nur smart sind im Sinne von da ist nur eine CPU drin, sondern eben auch äh in der Regel connected sind, also sich dann
auf irgendwelchen Cloud-Diensten einbuchen, um da Sachen zwischenzuspeichern, zu sünken.
Oder warum auch immer sie das tun wird das natürlich auch ein immer größeres Problem.
Ich würde das noch ganz kurz ein bisschen ähm nochmal versuchen, noch mehr plastisch vor Augen zu führen, die.
Wir haben ja hier oft gesagt, IT-Sicherheit ist ein Prozess und kein Zustand. Und,
wenn man, was ich als Beispiel sehr gerne nehme ist, dieses Windows XP, ne, Windows XP wurde dreizehn Jahre lang alle zwei Wochen oder wie das ist, mit Updates versehen,
und das war danach immer noch nicht fertig. Das war einfach nur Fehler und Probleme, die an diesem
an diesem Betriebssystem gefixt wurden. Und jetzt gehen wir hin und sind soweit, dass wir, ja, im Prinzip
in Geräten für wenige Euro, ein IP Stick, ein ein Betriebssystem zum Beispiel und ein Webserver und was nicht alles haben
ja? Und diese Geräte aber bei weitem nicht so gut mit uns interagieren können,
und dieses Thema, dieses Problem, Computer, der gepflegt werden muss, das ist jetzt nicht mehr nur ein Gerät im Haus, sondern das sind bald potentiell vielleicht einfach,
alle Geräte, weil du heute kein keine Steckdose mehr kaufen kannst ohne WLAN, keine Glühlampe ohne WLAN,
überall in diesen Dingern eben Software läuft und die braucht Pflege und die beste Möglichkeit, dem Produktpreis zu drücken.
Ist natürlich diese an dieser Pflege zu sparen an dieser Produkt Nachsorge zu sparen, wenn du,
und solange du nicht gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet bist, die zu leisten. Und das macht den Unterschied zwischen teuren und billigen Geräten aus, desto
ich nehme bei Aldi an der Kasse dir ein ein Android kaufen kannst, was schon irgendwie seit äh zwei Jahren ins Museum gehört
ich weiß es jetzt, ich ich übertreibe jetzt, ne, aber zum niedrigen Preis, die irgendein Discounter-Handy kaufen kannst und eben von einem anderen Hersteller ein um ungleich teureres Gerät mit sagen wir mal, technisch,
wenig Unterschied, ja, aber eben,
hier du einen einen Anbieter hast, der Nachsorge für dieses Gerät betreibt. Und das bedeutet ja, letztendlich für die Konsumentinnen einen,
dass in einer sehr wichtigen Geräte Qualitätsdimension ein stattfindet,
und solange es dort keine einheitlichen Vorschriften gibt, werden eben Anbieter immer versuchen, an dieser Stelle zu sparen.
Ja, als wären eben, als wären Sicherheitsgurte im Auto nicht vorgeschrieben.
Insofern ist jetzt interessant mal zu schauen, was diese Update-Pflicht jetzt so abdeckt. Hier ist davon die Rede, dass das ähm
sich auf alles bezieht, was beim Kauf eines Gerätes vorinstalliert war oder auch nur zum beim Zeitpunkt des Kaufes,
versprochen wurde und äh eine erweiterte Komponente davon ist. Das bezieht sich also vor allem so auf Apps, die man dann später auf dem Smartphone runterlegt, die ja technisch betrachtet, so erstmal nicht ausgeliefert werden, ne. Aber du kaufst so deinen Staubsaugerroboter und dann hat er halt eine App und diese App ist quasi ja,
integraler Bestandteil dieses äh Produktes, zumindest für die ganzen Heizversprechen, die das Ding so von sich gibt.
Das hat natürlich dann auch ganz interessante Auswirkungen auf äh darauf, was ist denn eigentlich vorinstalliert? Also wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel so einen Fernseher kaufst.
So ein Smart TV, dann kommen die ja dann in der Regel auch so mit äh vorinstallierten Sachen für, keine Ahnung, Party, Streaming, also
Netflix natürlich oder Disney Plus, so die ganzen großen Sachen, Apple, TV, Plus und diese ganzen Dienste.
Tube drin, der Fernseher hat YouTube drin.
Genau, so, ne? Und in dem Moment, wo das also vorinstalliert ist, würde dann eben auch sich diese Updatepflicht darauf beziehen. Gut, kann man jetzt sagen, bei diesen großen Anbietern ist es eben kein Problem, aber in dem Moment, wo jemand sich eben auch auf diese.
Bevorzugte Ebene katapultieren lässt, entweder eigener Popularität oder eben indem man sich äh in so ein Produkt mit einkauft.
Dann äh würde natürlich dann auch diese Update-Pflicht greifen. Klingt jetzt alles erstmal sehr schön, gibt aber auch noch ein Problem, denn in diesem,
Referentenentwurf ist kein konkreter Zeitraum vorgegeben
ähm der jetzt sozusagen gelten soll. Also wie viele Jahre gilt denn jetzt sozusagen das äh tatsächlich? Und ähm das ist mir jetzt hier auch noch so ein bisschen unklar ähm hier wird davon gesprochen, dass von Zeiträumen ausgegangen wird, die.
Ein Verbraucher als angemessen ansehen kann,
Also da könnte ich mir gibt's, glaube ich, sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu, ne. Ähm.
Also kommt's letzten Endes auf den Kaufvertrag und damit das konkrete Angebot äh an, auch der konkrete Umfang dieser Updates,
ist auch noch so ein bisschen unklar. Also, was ist denn jetzt damit gemeint? Müssen jetzt Bugs gefixt werden? Sind das Security-Features oder sind das Feature-Updates so, also wofür gilt dann eigentlich äh was, ja?
Ähm einzig ist davon die Rede, dass bei dauerhaft bereitgestellten digitalen Elementen.
Und das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, worauf sich das beziehen kann. So, aber klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie so die Kernfunktionalität, sollen Updates mindestens für zwei Jahre gelten und sie sollen auf jeden Fall eine Mängelfreiheit sicherstellen. Also,
fixen, ne? Und natürlich damit auch Security äh Sachen fixen. Das scheint so ein bisschen der Konsens zu sein, auf den's hinausläuft und muss sagen, mit zwei Jahren.
Wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal was verbessert. So, nicht nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, zwei Jahre für den ausreichen.
Aber das ist ja hier auch eine Frage von.
Existiert dieser Prozess überhaupt an sich oder nicht? Ne, du hast ja auch teilweise was weiß ich, gibt's noch Töne, Spielzeugkram, China, Klimby und so weiter, was weiß ich. Da lebt dann die App vielleicht nur ein halbes Jahr, bevor sie dann wieder aus irgendeinem App Store rausgekickt wird.
Da hast du natürlich dann irgendwie überhaupt nichts mehr von und sehr viel gerät.
Wird dann halt auch einfach nicht mehr benutzbar. Also du kaufst zwar irgendeine Hardware, aber in dem Moment, wo diese Apps wegfallen,
kannst du einfach diese Kernfunktionalität einfach überhaupt nicht mehr äh sicherstellen. Interessant in diesem Zusammenhang ist, dass die Gewährleistung für
Updates ähm wohl auf zwölf Monate angehoben werden soll, von üblicherweise sechs Monaten, also da geht's sozusagen um diese Beweisumkehr, also wer muss nachweisen, dass irgendwas fehlerhaft ist oder nicht? So ähnlich hast du das ja auch beim normalen Warenverkauf,
Also.
Es gibt da wohl angebliches, das habe ich jetzt aber nicht nachgeschlagen, es geht nur aus diesem Bericht hervor, eine Kostenkalkulation, wo sie insgesamt von fünf Jahren ausgehen.
Und ähm stellst dir natürlich jetzt auch die Frage, was wäre denn jetzt hier eigentlich wirklich realistisch? So, also ich denke so ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre, da kann man sich schnell drauf einigen. Also so ein Produkt, was irgendwie keine zwei Jahre überlebt.
Einfach auch keine digitale Komponente. Das, das, das ist irgendwie unseriös und ich würde sogar sagen, eigentlich könnte man auch drei von drei Jahren ausgehen.
Ja
Ähm und man könnte es vielleicht auch dahingehend erweitern, dass bestimmte Kategorien von Produkten.
Ja, also sagen wir mal so, die so eine gewisse Langlebigkeit in sich tragen. Ich denke da an Haushaltsgeräte, Kühlschränke, ja, äh der Staubsaugerroboter und so. Das sind ja nicht unbedingt Sachen, die man sich jetzt nur für zwei oder drei Jahre kauft.
Wenn man's jetzt über fünf Jahre hinaus denkt, dann wird's wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwierig, weil da muss man ja auch sehen, dass man dann vielleicht.
Unternehmen ein bisschen zu viel zumutet, ja.
Absolut, ja.
Also irgendwo ist auch mal Schluss so. Äh man kann sich ja mal den Smartphone-Markt anschauen, also lässt sich, glaube ich,
relativ unumstritten feststellen, dass Apple derzeit so ein bisschen der Update-Weltmeister ist, also man kann äh heute noch für Geräte, die fünf Jahre alt sind, das aktuelle Betriebssystem fahren.
Und bekommt auch Security Updates für Systeme, die teilweise noch älter sind.
Dafür zahlst du aber auch natürlich Preise, ne? Und das ist
ja. Äh ich glaube, also da werden die Leute sich in den Kommentaren melden, dass sie sagen, dass das wahrscheinlich äh ist im Androidbereich die Premiumanbieter wahrscheinlich ähnlich lange die Geräte unterstützen. Würde ich jetzt mal vorsichtig vermuten.
Tja, was sind denn da die Premiumanbieter?
Weiß ich nicht. Was ist das beste Gericht bei McDonald's?
So, jetzt hast du sie dir eingetreten.
Ich wollte doch nur darauf hinaus.
Dass selbst bei einer Marge wie Apple sie nimmt, ja,
und ähm einer, einer, einer, einer, einer Verbreitung und Wichtigkeit eines Produkts, was ja so ein Smartphone einfach hat, also
diese Kategorie, die ich da grade eben mal so äh aufgemacht habe, ja, so was ist sozusagen ein wichtiges, langlebiges Produkt. So, dann würde ich halt sagen, ja, okay, genau, also Smartphone würde das auf jeden würde auf jeden Fall die höchste Stufe an Update Pflicht erreichen müssen, wenn man das versucht, in verschiedene Kategorien einzuteilen.
Und da bin ich dann halt sagen, da warum nicht drei Jahre fest vorschreiben, ja,
und äh einen Prozess schaffen, eine Deklarationspflicht äh schaffen, wo Hersteller dann auch auf eine definierte Art und Weise das mit auf die Produkt
draufschauen, wie viel Jahre es denn jetzt sind.
Relativ sicher, wenn es so etwas gäbe, dann würde bei Apple würden diese drei Jahre äh ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken äh gewährleistet werden
Ja, dass sie einfach sagen können, ja, also für unsere Produkte auf jeden Fall drei Jahre und wenn sie der Meinung sind, sie wollen diese fünf Jahre Schwelle auch äh vertraglich zusichern, dann steht da halt auch noch eine Fünf drauf. Aber zehn Jahre.
Eher nicht.
Zehn Jahre ist natürlich ein krasses Risiko für kannst du dich irgendwann nicht mehr trauen, Produkt auf den Markt zu bringen, aber also als CCC haben wir da ja schon längere Zeit eine Position zu, also erstmal Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum und Update Pflicht
sind Forderungen des CCC seit langer Zeit, ja? Ähm also mit anderen Worten eine Mindestzeit
ein Gerät mit Updates versorgt werden muss. Es gibt aber natürlich bestimmte Corner-Cases. Was ist mit ähm,
Quell offener Software, was es mit Community-Projekten, die ihr auch irgendwie in dem Bereich des Verbraucherschutzes äh geraten hier und.
Eine wichtige Forderung, die wir ähm als CCC äh in diesen Bereichen,
immer auch damit kombinieren ist zu sagen, natürlich muss einem Betreiber,
Zum Beispiel auch die Möglichkeit gegeben sein, einen Service abzukündigen. Sagen wir mal, ähm Amazon hat jetzt, ne, die haben jetzt ein paar hunderttausend oder paar Millionen von diesen Echos da verkauft und eines,
eines eines traurigen Tages werden die halt sagen, so.
Diese uralt Echos werden irgendwie nicht mehr unterstützt werden von unserer Cloud. Aus welchem Grunde auch immer. Dieser Tag wird irgendwann kommen.
Und dann stellt sich die Frage, was machen jetzt die Verbraucherinnen mit den Dingern in der Bude? Schmeißt ihr die alle weg?
Oder dir diese oder die sagen, der kriegt keine Softwareupdates mehr und dann hat der irgendwann,
eine Schwachstelle. So, jetzt bei, bei so einem Echo Dot ist das noch relativ einfach. Wir nehmen mal ein anderes Beispiel. Ich habe hier ähm zum Beispiel betreibe ich zu Hause, da kann man sehr schön daran ähm am Beispiel nennen.
Steckdosen mit WLAN. Ja, habe ich. Die sind von einem äh China-Hersteller an eine App gebunden.
Äh auch ein einfacher Schaltvorgang erfordert sowohl für die Steckdose eine Internetkollektivität als auch für die zu der Steckdose gehörige App und was sie da kommunizieren, wenn man sich das in Wire Shark anschaut,
dann stehen einem die Haare zu Berge, als hätte man mit der Zunge in der Steckdose geleckt, ja? Das ist ganz, ganz schlimm.
Warum hast du denn so was.
Weil man die Flaschen kann mit einer eigenen Open-Source-Firm.
So
Das mache ich, ja? Das äh ich habe natürlich hier meine eigene selbst kombinierte äh auf den Steckdosen so, ne? Und ähm die,
sprechen die Protokolle, die ich für notwendig erachte, in den Sicherheitseinstellungen, die ich für notwendig erachte. Und ähm.
Ich bin Herrscherin über diese Steckdosen, weil da drin ist auch nur ein ESP zweiunddreißig und ein zweihundertdreißig Volt Relaye. So mit anderen Worten, ich kann,
Geräte sorgenfrei kaufen, ja? Ich könnte jetzt sogar äh weil ich in der Lage bin, dass wenn die Herstellerin sagt, äh
wir unterstützen's, wir schalten die Cloud ab und damit den Strom bei dir zu Hause, ja? Ähm dass man diese Dinger dann eben frei flaschen kann. Hier mit einer Communityfirma, die heißt Tasmota. Ähm.
Aber noch eine andere, habe ich nur vergessen, wie die heißt. Also es gibt mehrere, da habe ich vergessen, wie die heißt. Ähm,
da setzen wir zumindest als CCC an und sagen so, wenn dieses Gerät ähm abgekündigt wird, also wenn du zum Beispiel sagst, so diesen Router.
Unterstützen wir jetzt nicht mehr mit Security-Updates. Und äh oder dieses
dieses äh diese Cloud schalten wir ab, dass du dann als Herstellerin verpflichtet bist, deinen Kundinnen die Möglichkeit des Weiterbetriebes zu ermöglichen,
Sei es, indem du sagst, okay, hier ist der für die ähm für die Software, die darauf läuft, passt die von mir aus an, betreibt eure eigene Cloud. Ähm oder, oder, oder, ja?
Und das halte ich eigentlich für eine für eine relativ sinnvolle Forderung. Nicht nur weil du damit sagen kannst, ne, also ist jetzt nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen, dass alle Kunden das dann auch tatsächlich machen. Aber es wäre ja potentiell gar nicht so uninteressant, wenn die sagen.
Ach geil, so okay, der Hersteller hat das abgekündigt. Jetzt flache ich,
dieses alte Gerät, dem werden jetzt, wird jetzt neues Leben eingehaucht durch 'ne coole Community Software und.
Man darf nicht vergessen, dass das eben auch ökologische Aspekte hat. So,
das WLAN, was in dieser Steckdose ist, das wird noch viele Jahre laufen und auch das Stromnetz wird sich nicht ändern. Insofern wird es eigentlich,
nach menschlichem Ermessen relativ lange keinen Grund geben, dass sich diese Steckdosen durch neue ersetze oder sie einer Entsorgung zuführe, wenn aber hier der der Chinese die Cloud abschaltet
dann äh landen von diesem Hersteller sackweise diese Steckdosen im Müll und das ist ein Problem. Also Fazit.
Forderungen des CCC letztendlich, wenn du schon das, wenn du das Produkt abkündigst oder die die die Nachsorge für das Produkt abkündigst, Verpflichtung, ähm eine weitere, eine, eine eigene Pflege der Community zu ermöglichen.
Das wird aber Wischiwaschi bleiben müssen, weil es natürlich extrem schwierig ist zu definieren, A was ist eine ausreichende Dokumentation, ja, du kannst ja nicht davon ausgehen, dass du jetzt für jedes deiner Produkte auch automatisch äh eine Community findest, die jetzt äh da Bock drauf hat. Üblicherweise ist es so, es gibt halt im Markt
in jeder Produktkategorie zwei, drei Produkte, äh die finden jetzt alle irgendwie geil, weil die so ein bisschen den Nagel aufn
getroffen haben, ja, aber viel anderes ähm denken die Leute sich so, hm na ja, nee, guck mal hier, die Plastikschüssel und so weiter, die können ja alle irgendwie das nicht und dies nicht und äh,
da werfen wir uns jetzt auch gar nicht drauf. Also du kannst jetzt keine Erfolgsgarantie geben, dass das stattfindet,
dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, wenn keine Community da ist, die in irgendeiner Form was übernehmen kann, wer definiert denn dann auch die Qualität der Übergabe? Also wann ist denn wirklich alles erforderlich? Ist denn wirklich auch wirklich jedes Hardware-Detail dokumentiert, was du brauchst und es wird dich äh in Betrieb nehmen zu können
wenn dann niemand da ist, der das entweder,
überprüft, was ja dann ja auch ein teurer Prozess wäre oder eine Community, die sich zumindest lautstark zu Wort melden kann oder das in irgendeiner Form absegnen kann,
auch schwierig ist, weil die ja keine juristische Identität ist. Also ich sehe da praktisch noch Probleme, aber durchaus äh
für so eine Art.
Movement, ja, dass man sagt so, okay, es gibt hier so eine so so ein offenes äh Memorandum auf Understanding, äh wenn man das und das äh unterstützt, dass man eben bei diesen Produkten
eine Übergabe unter diesen äh Gesichtspunkten macht, aber ist ein bisschen schwierig. Auch das ökologische Argument muss ich sagen, hm
Ja gut, bei deinen Steckdosenschaltern mag das
äh so sein, aber viele alte Router möchtest du wahrscheinlich allein schon deshalb nicht mehr benutzen, weil die gerade viel zu viel Strom verbrauchen. Ja und neue Geräte wiederum deutlich weniger machen. Denn nur Kühlschränke et cetera äh haben wir das jetzt auch über viele Jahre gesehen.
Ich will jetzt nicht dem dem Argument generell widersprechen, will nur sagen,
Ist auch knifflig und insofern jetzt auch erstmal ganz gut, dass wir hier vielleicht den aller, aller ersten Schritt sehen, zumal es sich ja eben um die Umsetzung einer EU-Richtlinie handelt, da musste also sozusagen eh geschehen und jetzt wollen wir mal gucken,
ähm ob dann auch die Zeiträume noch konkreter werden können.
Also immerhin ist das ein Gesetzesvorhaben, was jetzt grade noch verhältnismäßig wenig Aussicht darauf hat, äh einen einen großen Schaden anzurichten und sogar Aussicht darauf hat
positive Konsequenzen zu haben. Und das ist, denke ich, durchaus, das können wir würdigen, als eine gute Nachricht. Denn da kann man auch einfach mal fünfe Grade sein lassen und sagen, das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Meinst du? Okay, okay. Ja, dann war das zumindest nochmal eine gute Nachricht.
Gibt ja noch eine, oder?
Ähm ja, kann schon sein, denn es gibt ein Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts,
zum Antiterrordatei-Gesetz A T D G, das geht locker von der Zunge. Kennt ihr sicherlich auch alle,
nämlich schon seit zweitausendsechs.
So ein bisschen wie TKKG.
Ah, hat so ein bisschen was davon, war aber nicht ganz so.
Ja, na ja, aber wurde ähm.
Wurde sozusagen ähm jetzt muss ich grad mal in die Timeline gucken, wann das eigentlich ergänzt wurde. Auf jeden Fall,
eine Formulierung in diesem Antiterrordatei-Gesetz, die dem.
Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht so gut gefallen hat. Dieses Anti.
Terrordateiengesetz, geht noch nicht so richtig flüssig von der Zunge, merke ich grade. Wurde später dann noch um eine weitere Vorschrift ergänzt, die sogenannte Paragraph sechs A, erweiterte
projektbezogene Datennutzung und da ging's nämlich dadrum, dass das alles,
um ähm ja so eine Datamining Komponente ergänzt äh werden sollte. Ja, ein Datamining von in der Antiterrordatei gespeicherten Datenarten.
Und zwar über die Informationsanbahnung hinaus auch zur operativen Aufgabenwahrnehmung
Paragraph sechs A. Gestattet, damit die unmittelbare Nutzung der Anti-Terror-Datei auch zur Generierung neuer Erkenntnisse aus den Querverbindungen der gespeicherten Datensitze. Dies war bisher
nur in alle Fällen möglich und das hat sich also das Bundesverfassungsgericht,
angeschaut. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wer da geklagt hat, egal. Auf jeden Fall,
war die Feststellung, dass diese Erweiterung, diese erweiterte, projektbezogene Datennutzung.
Artikel eins, Absatz eins des Grundgesetzes unvereinbar ist,
zur Erinnerung, da steht drin, die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar, sie zu achten und zu schützen ist Verpflichtung aller staatlichen Gewalt.
Schwierig da äh gegen anzugehen. So, ansonsten sei es verfassungsgemäß, aber das äh würde halt nicht so gut passen und äh diese Regelung, die dort halt eingeführt wurde, verletzt äh den ähm Beschwerdeführer,
von dem ich jetzt nicht genau weiß, wer es ist, in seinem Grundrecht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung.
Dementsprechend muss das rausgenommen werden. Was das ja letztlich ist, ist äh quasi so eine Art.
Fahndung in dieser Antiterrordatei und.
Jetzt muss das wieder anders beschlossen werden. Beziehungsweise ist diese Ergänzung nicht mehr gültig.
Okay. Das wahrscheinlich erstmal gut.
Klingt erst mal äh gut, müssen wir mal gucken, äh was das jetzt für Folgen hat.
Okay, habe ich direkt noch eine gute Nachricht.
Echt.
Der Finanzausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags hat beschlossen, dass Freifunk gemeinnützig ist.
Und ähm.
Das war auch wir haben das hier immer mal wieder behandelt eine äh über längere Zeit eine äh eine Diskussion.
Weil eben.
Ist, also was gemeinnützig ist und was nicht, dafür gibt's spezifische Zwecke, die ein Verein haben muss und die er verfolgen muss und sonst bist du nicht äh gemeinnützig. Ich äh habe das ja schon oft hier zitiert, als der Verein digitale Gesellschaft
gegründet wurde, hatte der in seiner Satzung irgendwie den Schutz von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten als Vereinszweck,
und dann gab's eben die Antwort, der Schutz von Grund- und Freiheitsrechten ist kein gemeinnütziger Zweck.
Ja und dann äh weil wenn du dir das nämlich äh anschaust, was ein gemeinnütziger Zweck ist, wir sind ja in Deutschland, das definiert. So und das müssen, da gibt's einfach ein ein Limited Set
auf äh gemeinnützige Zwecke und einige sind es eben nicht. Und bei Freifunk gab es dann eben die Diskussion.
Ob nun das Bereitstellen von äh kostenlosen freien Internetzugängen,
in diesem Subset gemeinnütziger Zwecke ist. Und äh,
ich denke natürlich klar, dass weil das ja der Zugang zu Bildung und so weiter ist, ja? Ähm aber äh das stand eben zur Frage und jetzt hat das eben ähm,
inzwischen endlich der Finanzausschuss eingesehen, dass das eben ein, eine.
Ein gemeinnütziges Engagement ist und das bedeutet eben, dass Spenden an die Freifond-Community eben auch steuerlich absetzbar sind. Das ist ja das.
Wichtigste, ja? Äh was so eine Gemeinnützigkeit eben,
ausmacht und je nachdem, wo du dich befindest, ne, ich meine in manchmal ist Freifunk einfach nur, dass jemand ein offenes WLAN für dich hat, aber in anderen Bereichen werden ja hier über Mesh-Netzwerke irgendwie halb Berlin verbunden.
Um das Internet irgendwo hinzubringen. Wir erinnern uns auch ähm um um zwanzig sechzehn äh diese großen
ähm oder zwanzig fünfzehn sogar schon diese großen Initiativen, um Geflüchteten in Unterkünften akzeptable WLAN-Verbindungen zu liefern, all das in in natürlich ehrenamtlichen Engagement und natürlich.
Gehört. Äh äh gehört dieses Engagement als gemeinnützig äh gefördert.
Ja, das ist alles sehr ähm schön, dass das so gekommen ist, aber jetzt muss man natürlich auch sehen, dass das äh sich noch weiter aus.
Breiten muss. Also da kann es nicht bei Freifunk bleiben, sondern das müssen müssen auch noch andere äh Dinge gemeinnützig sein.
Da gibt's noch eine ganze Menge anderer Sachen, die die gemeinnützig sind.
Weil es wirklich interessant, wenn man sich mal anschaut, was heutzutage als gemeinnützig anerkannt wird, also es ist eine.
Halt so Sachen, so allgemeine Formulierungen drin, so Förderung von Wissenschaft und Forschung, Bildung und Erziehung,
Kunst und Kultur, Völkerverständigung und so weiter, Denkmalschutz, Naturschutz
Tierschutz ist alles drin, Sport, ja, ja, aber was weiß ich, wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel Open Source Software äh verbreiten möchtet, also freie Software, die äh Dinge tut, so, dann gibt's da überhaupt gar keinen Ansatz.
Ja
Vielleicht könnte man das demnächst mal als Brauchtum deklarieren.
Weil äh die Förderung des traditionellen Brauchtums, einschließlich des Karnevals, der Fastnacht und des Faschings ist auch mit drin
ich würde sagen, wenn so Karnevalsvereine gemeinnützig sein können, dann könnte man das eigentlich auch mal mit einem Projekt hinkriegen.
Ja, das ist mein Brauchtum. Ich mache das schon immer. Und manchmal hat man auch wirklich so den Eindruck, um ehrlich zu sein, dass so in der freien Software-Szene auch.
Sehr karnevalistisch zugeht.
Ja, aber wie, also man hätte, ich sage mal so, dass der das Bereitstellen von Internet der Völkerverständigung dient.
War längere Zeit unstrittig. Ja, inzwischen muss man sich fragen, ob das eventuell tatsächlich nicht der Völkerverständigung dient.
Aber da gibt's ja noch äh Hilfe für äh religiös verfolgte Flüchtlinge, vertriebene Aussiedler, also da passt das auch mit rein.
Okay, kommen wir, kommen wir zum letzten Brauchtum. Auch hier nochmal eine positive Meldung. Soll ich machen?
Ja. Corona-Warn-App gibt's jetzt auch in mit ohne Google.
Ja, endlich.
Und sie sagen etwas, was ich natürlich sehr spannend finde. Sie sagen, die eine Handvoll freier Softwareentwickler hat heute erreicht, was äh offizielle Stellen seit Monaten nicht hinbekommen haben. Die deutsche Corona-Warn-App.
Ähm komplett frei vondependenties auf Google und erhältlich in Froid, dem Free Software App Store.
Super, ne? Das erweitert jetzt den potentiellen Nutzerinnenkreis dieser App, muss man ganz einfach sagen, ne? Ähm,
und es äh ermöglicht, Ahoch für die interessierte Nutzerin
jetzt hier ähm Ergänzungen an der App vorzunehmen, ja? Also es gibt ja viele, die sagen, ich möchte genau wissen, wann ein Kontakt war. Das ist jetzt nur ein kleiner Patch.
In der quelloffenen Implementierung des.
Google, Apple, ähm contact tracing, Frameworks, hier eben in freigebaut.
In dieser Applikation. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob die ebenfalls so ähm energiesparend laufen kann, dass,
dafür habe ich mir das nicht genau angeschaut, wie sie das gebaut, nicht genau genug angeschaut, wie sie das gebaut haben. Ich denke, das wird man einfach sehen. Aber ähm ja,
zeigt doch einfach mal diese Community und ich sage jetzt mal bewusst ihre Stärke, denn ja, das hat jetzt
lange gedauert, ne. Wir haben Dezember. Aber ich meine, die haben das in in äh in ehrenamtlicher Arbeit und aus ja in irgendeiner Form von Enthusiasmus gemacht. Ähm und.
Dass äh ja, ich denke, das muss man tatsächlich mal äh wirklich als als Stärke würdigen und auch als äh dieses Engagement eben zeigen, ne, dass es eben nicht.
Ähm also dass dieser ganze freie Softwaregedanke und diese App überhaupt open Source zu machen, eben tatsächlich hier auch noch Monate später entscheidende Früchte trägt.
Finde ich wirklich super.
Ja, es äh auf jeden Fall zu begrüßen. Ich muss zugeben, ich bin etwas ähm skeptisch, was so den Erhalt des äh Entwicklungsprinzips betrifft, weil grade bei diesem
Exposur Notification Framework, was ja Google und Apple vorantreiben, was die ja jetzt quasi nachprogrammiert haben, ne? Ähm
stehen ja demnächst größere Umwälzungen an, also die äh Version zwei null des Protokolls, das ist so das Roll-out, was wir jetzt gerade sehen
mir jetzt gerade gar nicht so sicher, ob das in einem aktuellen Betriebssystemrelease schon drin ist oder erst noch kommt. Auf jeden Fall äh ändern sich dann zum Beispiel grundlegende Dinge, wie die
Berechnung des Risikos et cetera. Also da wird dieser gesamte Algorithmus nochmal komplett umgestellt. Sprich, in dem Moment hat man hat man natürlich dann auch den Druck,
relativ zügig dann, da kann man nicht ewig warten, weil äh das ja auch mit der mit dem Betrieb des Servers zusammenhängt, der dann diese Parameter liefert, die müssen dann halt auch entsprechend umgesetzt werden,
und das dann halt eben auch zeitnah, weil sonst ist man einfach schlicht inkompatibel. Ich sage nicht, das geht nicht, ich sage nur,
Hier sieht man was äh was eine Bereitstellung von Software ist jetzt nicht so ein hier habt ihr das und
passt schon und dann wird das ewig laufen bei dieser.
Pflicht, ne? Äh dann muss das natürlich auch mental werden und man muss äh Probleme lösen, man muss Bugs fixen, man muss äh auf äh entsprechende Protokolländerungen,
reagieren.
Total, total richtig. Ich denke, also es wird aber keine also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass es ähm.
Protokolländerung geben wird die Backwort Kompatibility brechen. Ähm.
Aber natürlich in dem Moment, wo du ein Softwareprojekt startest und das in die Welt setzt, hast du das Ding an der Backe. Und das ist ja auch die Stärke dieser Community,
sie nicht nur das geschafft hat, sondern das ist bis zur Release-Fertigkeit geschafft haben und gerade Leuten, die sowas machen, denen ist auch klar, dass natürlich jetzt das Ding an der Backe haben und da in Zukunft,
nachiplementieren müssen, ja? Wenn wenn es signifikante Änderungen gibt und so. Im Moment haben sie aber, muss man jetzt auch sagen, natürlich die Nase vorn, weil sie eben Features haben,
über die viel diskutiert wird, ne,
gerade hier, ich kann nicht sehen, wann der Kontakt war, großes Thema, ne? Wird der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte für verantwortlich gemacht und was da nicht alles diskutiert wird? Die haben's halt mit ein paar Zahlencode jetzt einfach mal geschafft und haben jetzt, muss man wahrscheinlich sagen.
Die bessere Corona-Warnapp für einen kurzen Zeitpunkt, bis halt wieder die tatsächliche sich weiterentwickelt und sie dann gucken müssen, ob sie ob das ähm.
Merchbar bleibt für sie, oder ob das ihrerseits Arbeit und Anpassung erfordert, aber sie haben sich dieser Aufgabe gewidmet und verfolgen das jetzt. Und das doch wichtig.
Ist okay. Also das könnte auch interessante Auswirkungen haben, wenn halt bestimmte Features, die derzeit blockiert sind, dann einfach mal praktisch gezeigt werden. Ja, so nach dem Motto gucke mal, so schön könnte das sein, dann ist das natürlich auch äh ja, interessant.
Ne? Das kann äh also herzlichen Glückwunsch und äh Respekt, dass das so geschaffen wurde. Ja und natürlich andererseits eben auch schade, dass es.
Ich sage ja, bei zwanzig Millionen wäre das vielleicht äh drin gewesen sowas auch noch zu machen, ne. Ich meine, dafür musste sich das darf man ja auch nicht sagen, äh darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, es mussten sich halt diese, diese Abhängigkeit von den Google Diensten war für eine.
Für eine ausreichend große Community ein Grund, die App nicht zu installieren oder nicht installieren zu können. Denke man an die Huawei-Telefone, die eben aufgrund der Sanktionen.
Der USA von den Google Services abgeschnitten sind, ne? Also es ist jetzt nicht nur ein Dienst an an den ähm.
Android äh äh reinen Fundamentalisten und Google frei von Leuten, sondern eben äh oder die es eben ne, gezielt und selbst entschieden so als,
wichtige ähm,
Entscheidung für sich so sehen, sondern eben auch Leuten, die halt ein Huawei-Phone gekauft haben und nicht wussten, dass da bestimmte Sachen eben drauf nicht funktionieren, weil der äh der äh
abgewählte US-Präsident äh meinte damit irgendwie China ärgern zu können, ja? Also das ist nicht nur nicht nur für.
Ähm wie nennt man das denn? Ich will jetzt nicht Fundamentalisten sagen, aber mir fällt gerade kein anderer Begriff ein. Ähm was ist ein.
Was ist denn ein positiver Begriff für Fundamentalist? Hm, Experte. So.
Genau, Experte ist gut. Ja, okay.
Sachverständiger, ja.
Dann kommen wir zum Ende der Sendung. Oder?
Ich äh weise hier noch mal darauf hin, dass ich äh in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt habe, ach nee, Quatsch, ich muss noch was sagen. In der letzten Sendung haben wir unsere Spendenaufrufe gemacht und haben wir gesagt, an wen man alles spenden kann, da haben wir wieder nur ähm auf äh an Deutschland äh gedacht und haben drei,
deutsche Gruppierung genannt, bei denen Geld immer gut investiert ist und haben dabei natürlich vergessen, dass wir auch auf der äh EU-Ebene.
Eine sehr wichtige Organisation haben, nämlich Edry European Digital Rights Ebri, finanziert finanziert sich.
Zu großen Teilen auch aus eben äh den Mitgliedsorganisationen, aber es ist auch wichtig, äh ne,
Edri davon unabhängig zu machen und man kann eben auch direkt an Edri spenden. Und ähm dazu verlinken wir jetzt hier auch noch einmal die äh Möglichkeiten,
ähm an Edri, monatlich.
Oder einmalig äh zu spenden und ich kann nur betonen, diese Arbeit auf der EU-Ebene.
Wird jedes Mal zusehend wichtiger, ja, wir.
Merken, dass äh immer weniger von dem, was in Lokbuch weltbewegend diskutiert wird
im Bereich der äh Bundesregierung oder der der Bundesrepublik stattfindet. Hier hier finden immer noch die größten Verkackungen statt. Das ist richtig. Aber äh die großen Weichenstellungen ähm,
sind in zunehmenden Maße auf der EU-Ebene und da müssen wir ein Auge drauf haben und da äh ist es sinnvoll, Edri zu zu unterstützen, weil das ist,
mehr oder weniger, dass der eine Dachverband, die eine Dachorganisation, die wir eben auf der EU-Ebene.
In als als NGO-Zusammenschluss haben.
Auch kein nennenswerter Mehraufwand, einfach in dem Moment, wo er den Dauerauftrag für äh Lochboot Netzpolitik aufgesetzt hat, einfach gleich noch einen für hinterher. Soul, so läuft das.
Easy. Ja. Spart man, da spart ihr euch zweimal den Zweifaktor Login. Das muss man ja auch irgendwie heute ökonomisch mit umgehen.
Ich hatte äh in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, dass ich aufgrund wiederholter Missverständnisse zum
Ende dieses Jahres damit aufhören werde in dieser Sendung äh Individuen persönlich zu danken.
Ähm und ich euch deshalb darum bitte, wenn ihr von mir,
Dank haben möchtet, mir eine Möglichkeit zukommen zu lassen, euch diesen Dank zum Ausdruck zu bringen. Das kann eine E-Mail-Adresse sein. Ähm und so weiter. Aber,
Ich danke an dieser Stelle Silvana, Dana, Pedro, Steffen, Frank, Philipp und Fabian.
Das war's schon, Tim.
Super.
Zurückgelegt.
Ja, ich lehne mich die ganze Zeit zurück so. Habe nur gerade aufm Kalender äh geschaut, mich gefragt, wie viele Sendungen wir dieses Jahr denn eigentlich noch machen werden. Also in einer Woche sind wir auf jeden Fall nochmal am Start, würde ich sagen.
Ja, also wir haben noch ein paar Sachen hier aufm Schirm. Die nächste Sendung wird äh Digital Services act, sicherlich Thema sein.
Geplant vielleicht.
Ja, wir versuchen ja immer über die ungelichten Eier nicht ganz so viel zu gackern.
Nö, das kommt dann vielleicht oder auch nicht. Müssen wir mal gucken. Also, könnte noch ein bisschen was passieren dieses Jahr. Aber so viel ja ist nicht mehr. Drei Wochen haben wir noch.
Nun, dann wollen wir euch jetzt auch nicht länger davon abhalten, den Rest dieses wundervollen Jahres auch weiterhin in vollen Zügen zu genießen,
Jetzt habt ihr schon so viel Zeit damit äh äh verbracht, uns zuzuhören in diesem Jahr. Muss man ja jetzt nicht unbedingt äh nennenswert noch in die Länge ziehen und überhaupt.
Nächstes Jahr wird alles noch geiler und äh von daher wünsche euch ein schönes Wochenende.
Wünschen wir euch ja tun wir. Bis dahin, ciao ciao.
Tschüss.